Pippa Middleton marries James Matthews
here are all the details you need to
know about their special day it was a
royal affair at st. Mark's Church on the
Engel field estate in England on
Saturday for Pippa and James's nuptials
the beautiful bride absolutely stunned
in this gorgeous custom-made white
girl's deacon gown with cap sleeves a
corseted bodice draped front and
heart-shaped detail in the back her hair
pulled up into an updo she paired with a
simple veil and dropped diamond earrings
Pippa was seen smiling from ear to ear
outside the church alongside her father
Michael Middleton just before heading
inside older sister Kate Middleton
looked beautiful in blush the Duchess of
Cambridge was seen adorably shushing the
children on their way into the church
and sweetly fluffing her sisters gown
before heading down the aisle we have a
very normal assistant relationship right
we're very close the couple said I do
surrounded by a hundred and thirty royal
family and friends including Pippa's
nephew three-year-old Prince George who
served as page boy and two-year-old
niece Princess Charlotte as bridesmaid
the little ones father Prince William
was seen alongside Prince Harry ahead of
the ceremony the two looking at dapper
as ever in almost matching tuxedos
William chose a burgundy tie with his
ensemble while Harry rocked blue
[Music]